كابوس طيران اذ ان طائره ركاب قامت بحركه
مفاجئه جنحت معها بعيدا عن خط سيرها
المستقيم ليس بسبب الطيار بل بسبب مسافر
جالس في الطائره هذا الرجل هو كريس روبرتس
وهو مستشار امن الكتروني واخبر مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي انه قام بالامر لفطح
نقاط الضعف الالكترونيه للطائره وقال
روبرتس انه امر برنامج القرصنه بجعل احد
محركات الطائره بوضعيه الاقلاع ما دفع
الطائره الى الاندفاع بحركه
جانبيه طاقم الطائره سينتبه الى اي ادخال
غريب على طائرتهم حتى ان كانت ضمن ضوابط
المحرك
والرحله وزعم روبرتس الى انه وصل في عده
حالات الى ما يسمى بصندوق الكرسي
الالكتروني تحت كراسي المسافرين ليشبه
كمبيوتره المحمول به ويخترق نظام الخدمات
الترفيهيه للطائره وبذلك يصل الى نظام
الطائره
والملاحه من المحير انهم يقومون بوضع
صناديق تحت الكراسي يمكنك وصل كمبيوترك
المحمول بها وصادر مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي اجهزه روبرتس الالكترونيه في
ابريل نيسان الماضي بعد ان غرد قائلا انه
قام بتفعيل اقنعه الاكسجين على متن رحله
جويه لخطوط يونايتد ودافعت شركات الطيران
عن نفسها اذ قالت بوينج ان نظام الترفيه
في طائراتها التجاريه منفصل عن نظامي الط
والملاحه لكنها لم تشرح كيفيه استقلال
الانظمه عن بعضها انها مفصوله من خلال
جدار حمايه او برنامج فقط لكنها في نفس
الجهاز واعتقد ان هذه مشكله اكثر خطوره
وحذر تقرير حكومي في ابريل نيسان من
المخاطر الالكترونيه المحتمله لخطوط
الطيران قائلا ان التقنيه بما في ذلك
انظمه اللاسلكي للمسافرين قد تخلق وصولا
غير مصرح به للمسافرين وتمكنهم من اختراق
انظمه الكترونيات
الطائره